everyone I'm David Griffin now Michael
Medina we're here to bring you this
week's review of arrow season 2 episode
17 birds of prey this is the episode for
the ladies ladies I'm doing it for
themselves giggles back in his suit not
doing anything they like it was like he
does it way too much last week yeah
Diggle did a little too much last week
no should be putting this place oh you
know uh so I thought it was good I
didn't love this episode as much as I
have some of the previous episodes
anything goes as good as heir to the
demon or some other ones even last week
you thought might have been a little
better i was really missing Deathstroke
well I shouldn't say that we did see
slain I should all get sauced laid in
the flashbacks but I kind of missed him
in his present day attire his present
day situation with men who've been that
so I don't know what you think was
episode I agree I enjoyed the episode I
thought it was good but especially like
after last week's episode it was kind of
a step back yeah I was really excited
when birds of prey naturally I mean you
want to be excited I'm looking forward
to this and I was but yeah it's just no
it's something about it just in really
quite good episode was good no solid
just wasn't as good i think it's not the
previous episodes uh let's talk about i
I guess we've been bashing her so much
so we had talked about Laurel yeah roul
kicks some butt she's a couple good
shots with couple of a couple one yeah a
couple karate Thompson able to give her
credit she hasn't had the training she
said yeah defensive class train she
hasn't trained like you know Sarah and
Ollie and all his people but she's still
like you were saying still kind of the
damsel in distress on yeah that's her
thing let's not forget I mean she is
dealing with a battle inside and into
the battle rez is dealing with hello my
name is Laurel and I'm an alcoholic hi
Laurel yeah that was yeah like I mean
turns me like look I have friends and
girlfriends people that we know for the
numbers that are alcoholics alcoholism
is a very serious thing or not making us
that's not funny but when it let me see
Laurel in the a meeting it's like I just
don't know if I take it seriously I just
don't I don't care about Laurel and an a
a meeting yeah and that's another reason
why I don't really care about this old
damsel in distress at senior she's
become no it's like she's kind of turned
into like that I don't know Lois Lane
Silver Age like Oh help me super like
always like get in trouble alright
something stupid then I get herself tied
up again after and I mean
you know again look at this but it looks
like at the end and this is going to be
hopefully it's gonna be a hot topic to
talk about this week in the comments
below what do you think Laurel is gonna
go after this it looks like they're kind
of one dark side with Laurel because
when she fights to get her job back
talking to the i'm guessing the district
attorney saying like you know you know
hey like she quoted hunter Spacely
hunter saying like well once you out the
darkness in you can never get it out of
you if you watch the trailer for next
week's episode like she likes whispers
that's all like creepy and weird so it's
Laurel going dark side I mean we're all
kind of thing that maybe she might be
Black Canary but could she be turned
into a villain like she might be going
dark side I i I'd like to see her do
something cuz like again I'm not hating
on the character I mean that she's there
for a reason I've said this before yeah
whether it be good or bad whatever but I
mean I I'd be down with her you know
turning bad yeah wonder what she's gonna
do I mean so this was again birds of
prey he's the ladies you see hunter is
good to see Black Canary no Oracle no no
no no Barbara Corbett's ok cool element
cool better the right for Gotham yeah
it's gonna be forgot them on Fox so uh
but we didn't get to see huntresses back
yeah it's been a while since we've seen
her she's good yeah but you know
honestly I was gonna ask you this I we
need to talk about this work Mike and I
watch the episode before this together
and I was watching it having been away
from her for over a year and are a year
at least now I'm like I don't think
she's as quite as good as Nisa al Ghul
she's I don't think she's quite as good
as Black Canary she was good but I
wasn't as impressed as or some other
female characters on the show no I agree
she's um kind of vanilla yeah i guess
like trying to be hard but yeah I just
raised the bar with their villains so
since she last appeared and the thing is
to it's like she's Huntress so it's like
I feel like she's not full villains like
she you know what I mean like she's real
crazy yeah cuckoo but you know so that's
why it's just like can't quite find that
right or you know and maybe if she gets
a chance to be on the show on a more
regular basis like I hope they do get
birds of prey together at least two of
the birds hopefully get Huntress and we
get Black Canary doing some work
together i hope so but i know i think is
last week you mentioned the whole like
Felicity kind of filling that oracle
yeah I think that'd be that'd be G she
could be Barbara Gordon base which you
can be honest that would be great I'm
again she was good but just like I think
like so they just raised the bar there's
so many good especially female
characters in the show that I'm just
like I don't know she carried her weight
as much
again to be fair she's been away from
the show for long times we'll see uh see
who else we have this me let's talk
about Roy no Roy no my boy Roy it's like
he got a little bit more screen time you
know a little more screen time Nolan
forum I want to see more you know but
you know you got was something kind of
see again he's dealing with that
struggle and he's obviously loves Thea
cares for Thea and Oliver knows this but
you know basically confronts him cells
in like you know you gotta do what's
best for people they pulled the old
Harry Potter spider-man of like oh you
know my enemies they were found out
about you know anus oh he's he's gotta
you know get away from the break up with
her again you know that's gonna have the
romance in there it sits lower we gotta
have a role nights in there so I like
that hopefully to see Roy do more I mean
he's still struggling with his major boo
boo hoo yeah he's struggling with his
anger so I mean he's got some issues to
work out absolutely and which but that's
good though because the whole theater
kind of leads us to that last scene yeah
you know see she kind of walks in a
slave limo isn't kind of yes arrow I
mean I realized this is like I think a
shot in Vancouver I realized CW has a
limited budget it's not game of thrones
money but it's like they walk down the
same back and why are all the alleys
smoking yeah my sister loves Birds City
Mike I live here in la all the streets
everything's smoking I'm like why is
everything smoking everything's always I
Ali's apartment wherever he lives in the
basement smokin looks like it twice or
so much steam is here the sewer system I
don't understand this but oh what
another thing we're picking on the show
but we love the show I'm just having a
good time also in in the verdant the
club when they're having a little
meeting in a middle of the club I was
like they show like the tub and then
this goes here there's like a laptop
stand on their iPad just like talking
like an even here with all the club not
going on no seriously to get back we did
get to see something from the island yes
we did I loved a woman so what do you
think about Black Canary on the island
there um yeah I thought you know she did
your black canary or Sarah on the island
I thought was good i was actually little
bit more you know geeking out for her as
black canary in this episode really key
it was focusing a little bit more and
obviously because it's you know birds of
prey on Black Canary so I thought like I
enjoyed her fats or fancy everything
Betsy yeah our fight scenes with the
Huntress I thought we were in training
and that was again what kind of like a
geek out
moment see those girls go at it but
again I mean I'm like like Black Canary
and I'd like to see more of her like in
this capacity I think the show you know
arrow and it's a good in a bad it
struggles from like the cast is just so
big yeah you know as much as we pick on
Diggle and everything like I want to see
more Diggle but there's this they got to
fit everybody else and Diggle even
though he's just in the background like
he that old tingle does his whole
episode is when Roy is watching the
camry sad he broke up with the aegis
does the you know like then he just
walks up like the house job is done for
ya son so again it's not that we don't
obviously you know that we love the show
yeah we're looking at right that's the
thing love these characters so much and
they're so good right yeah we just want
to see more and we understand it's like
you know you gotta take your time you
wanna you're trying to build this
universe yeah you know I don't want to
rush anything but yeah I definitely
would like to I guess cuz last week and
finally guy and I got that yeah slowly
shout with diggle's of Diggle yeah and
saw just how cool of a character Ricky
where he's just like giving a little bit
more time instead of just sitting around
in this suit and everything so but uh so
let's look ahead to the future we're
getting down to the nitty-gritty here we
have next week looks great right i mean
next week's episode 18 is called
Deathstroke yeah so we're gonna get some
desk I only gonna get that get some
extra Deathstroke and there's a scene I
don't want to pick a part 2 trailer too
much but there's a scene where it looks
like Ali's fighting a girl in an office
building could be my girl summer glau
all you keep telling me to stop mention
here a week after week I'm gonna
convince her until my girl comes good if
you watch this review got to deal with
that for the next few weeks oh she got
back because i love summers I don't know
where she's been maybe she shows up next
week like maybe she's Talia al Ghul may
no no that's too much that's gone too
far well she's gonna something
something's gonna happen there's
definitely gonna be a twist there
because again it certainly looked like
there was a girl like ya know that he
was and he put throws on a table or so
yeah and obviously I mean she was put on
the show for a reason yeah I'm play a
big part of this yeah there's there a
lot of like secrets that are being no
cat why does everybody have see dress oh
you're the only person doesn't lie to me
okay
oh you lied on your sister for Thea Thea
is gonna crash this season the
everybody's going to her all the girls
are going dark yeah yeah yeahs are funny
because he doesn't get that much screen
time but I actually kind of like fela
more than Laurel yeah things more
engineers 100 big part we have to talk
about before we go I almost forgot
speedy oh that's almost forgot that
alley called Roy speedy yeah to get his
attention exactly you know to kind of
draw him away from just like going just
batshit crazy we all know like red arrow
is called speedy so like when when he
called her sister speeding the first I
was like well we that's where is she
gonna be right here yeah but now that
she's not i don't think they had like a
little jokey-joke yes I don't ever call
me that again you know like me like
hahaha but at least like we did get to
hear Ali call yeah Roy and eventually
you know he's gonna get a code name with
whether it be red arrow arsenal I'm
thinking I'm thinking arsenal's maybe
because he looks like he can be ready oh
he's almost too dark right now in our
social darker character said he'd have
to Train I suppose unless you need a
trace you might just go full on our
social skills me yeah here's another
great action packed you know great
episode the ladies got a chance to shine
diggle's battery needs to be not doing
anything can't see my girl still so no
summer glau but that's okay the show
keeps going on next week's Deathstroke
you know stay tuned but as always you
come chat with a micro dinosaur myself
at think yo Comi also can check us out
on this YouTube page I think hero pro
make sure you go ahead and give us a
like subscribe for the word we're also
on Twitter dennis michael hunter on
twitter we're at think hero i'm at
griffin de nom at mr. Michael Alexis we
also the facebook page at facebook.com
slash think hero fans make sure you like
that page subscribe you know give us a
thumbs up spread the word social media
love you guys and we'll see you next
week
you